[Musique]
au centre de la france dans la vienne
le village de vivonne et paralysé par le
froid
trois mille habitants vivent ici et ce
soir il fait moins 9,2 hors
ma main va te faire chauffer toute nue
nathalie vit seule avec ses deux enfants
je fais chauffer l'eau du bain pour le
petit tous les soirs
nathalie patientent devant ses
casseroles
depuis le mode depuis fin octobre
cela fait quatre mois qu'elle vit sans
eau chaude ni chauffage on lui a coupé
le gaz suite à une facture impayée de
1400 euros depuis ces systèmes d seule
la cuisinière fonctionne gazinière
normalement ces gaz de ville donc j'ai
changé pour pouvoir mettre une bouteille
de gaz
c'est comme ça tous les jours pour la
vaisselle pour le ménage pour nous laver
c'est un rituel on va pas dire qu'on en
prend l'habitude parce qu'on fera jamais
l'habitude de ces mauvaises choses tu
viens avec ma main
du coup la porte
attention tu t'en mets mon cas moins de
monde dans la salle de bain il fait 12
degrés gouy il faut faire vite ouais
roisin murphy de la chasse épilateur
l'eau donc
peu dire 50 fois par jour d'un bal pour
lui c'est que du bonheur
[Musique]
il a fallu arriver à 44 ans pour
connaître
cette galère la
toux et you hate you et que je me dis
mon fils de deux ans qu'on est déjà la
misère à son âge quoi là mon chéri noël
comme en cette froide et tu vas vent
froid après hop hop hop hop hop vite
vite vite la foire bah oui je sais que
tu as from en amour
web os mobile
en congé parental depuis deux ans
nathalie touche 600 euros par mois seule
la chambre de son fils échauffé en
permanence et qui c'est qui va faire
dodo là tout encore ce soir
c'est ma maman va faire de toi danton
gandhi parce que dans la chambre maman
il fait trop froid fais de beaux rêves
je t'aime en émoi
à demain où normalement votre choix ma
chambre et ici
il fait extrêmement froid c'est le
sakai franchement je grelotte même sous
l'équateur grelotte donc non c'est pas
possible là ils doivent faire je sais
pas si cette tête 8 degrés et encore je
sais même pas
8 degrés dans sa chambre
14 dans le salon
[Musique]
combien y at-il de nathalie dans notre
pays
pour les rencontrer nous avons traversé
une france figée par le froid
ils ne sont pas tous en grande précarité
certains sont comme vous et non des
familles des retraités des travailleurs
c'est votre voisine votre mère votre
collègue
pourquoi est il devenu aussi difficile
de se chauffer maison mal isolée petits
salaires hausse spectaculaire des prix
de l'énergie ils sont 12 millions un
français sur cinq à souffrir du froid
chez eux
une nouvelle pauvreté qui porte un nom
la précarité énergétique
16h07 la météo sur france le poteau
c'est plutôt cool et froid ce matin ce
qu il fait -6 degrés actuellement à
vivonne
[Musique]
encore un matin gelé pour nathalie et
une journée qui commence mal sa voiture
est en panne
la totale c'est le démarreur et
apparemment j'en aurais pour à peu près
200 euros grand maxime et moi 200 euros
aujourd'hui c'est impossible pour moi
lui qui fait froid mon chaton dit tu dit
jean-michel son voisin a spontanément
proposé de l'emmener à la crèche et
voilà attention les mains
heureusement qu'il existe encore des
amis pour nous dépanner dans ces cas là
je ne peux pas la voir souffrir comme ça
et laissé dans le froid avec un petit
mot c'est pas possible
là il va être au chaud là la crèche
avant son congé parental nathalie était
cuisinière dans un centre de loisirs
elle a obtenu une place en crèche trois
demi journées par semaine des jours de
répit et de chaleur pour son fils
nathalie elle va passer la journée au
froid
de sakai
le pas de la porte passée elle a
toujours le même réflexe
vous étonner oui pour économiser un peu
le gaz tant que petit à la crèche et je
le rallume vrai
vers 15 heures normalement 15h30 pour se
réchauffer un peu la pièce pour pâques
ou pieds froids quand il va revenir de
la crèche
c'est 25 euros la bouteille de gaz effet
une semaine
du gaz devenu un produit de luxe
nathalie ne peut compter que sur deux
convecteurs électriques qu'elle déplace
d'une pièce à l'autre en fonction des
urgences
pour le mettre dans ma chambre ma fille
parce que ben a vu l'humidité et je vois
que salah a moisi de partout une
situation difficile dont sa fille
préfère ne pas témoigner
sans chauffage l'humidité envahi toute
la maison et 6 passes c'est tellement
évident que ben là tous les murs a moisi
le savez moisi à de l'eau partout
ça passe ou l'armure de ma fille
tu tombe trop bien de toi et à voir je
chanterai pété les plombs
c'est jean-michel le voisin qui vient de
sonner
[Musique]
champions
la maison en location n'est pourtant pas
si vieilles elles datent des années 70
mais ses constructions se dégradent vite
d'un garage
bah non il n'est pas isolé irène 10 où
les taux sont
ya rien d'isoler un peu de moisissures
mais de lourdes conséquences
take two s'accumuler ces vip
tout
non c'est pas normal parce que j'ai pas
de marbella scoop mans ce gaz
là j'ai tout qui prend la flotte et les
tapisseries tous y est
donc ça va être encore des frais en plus
après par la suite parce qu'il va
falloir tour au fort
des travaux inenvisageable pour
l'instant il faut se débrouiller avec
l'aide des amis même pour la douche
tous les jours depuis le mois d'octobre
nathalie vient se laver chez jean michel
et sa femme
fumant chez toi c'est meilleur ah bah
oui largement je vais squatter ta douche
pas de problème du cia je sais
ça c'est pas grand chose non mais non
c'est pas grand chose mais pour moi
c'est énorme tu connais le chemin on
voit là
ouais là j'ai le sourire car il sait que
un moment de normalité pour nathalie
dix minutes de chaleur et d'oubli
arraché à la réalité
[Musique]
paraît bloquée à - 20 à - 4 pour les
températures à l'heure actuelle nous
avons moins 5° toujours sur la métropole
lilloise
nous sommes remontés vers le nord
jusqu'au village de brême dans le
pas-de-calais
dans cet hiver glacial les plus
précaires sont bien sûr les plus touchés
nicolas a emménagé ici il ya trois
semaines en urgence avec sa femme cathy
et depuis trois semaines ils attendent
que l'hiver s'éloigne
fait 5 à 6 degrés je sois pas je
l'allumé mais beaucoup sur le sport de
masse
commises et que
la nuit pour dormir en barbie au matin
quand tu plais mais la première chose
c'est à l'humain tout petit peu le
chauffard je produis un économusée
j'ai plus de revenus j'ai plus de
travail je me suis retrouvé j'ai fait
aujourd'hui moi je me retrouve dans le
carnage
nicolas était ouvrier agricole
une perte d'emploi un statut fragile
d'auto entrepreneur et c'est la chute en
quatre mois le couple se retrouve à la
rue
avant de ton carbone jeté d'un bond sur
les voitures moi aussi son effet dans le
sens passé dans la caravane tu peux
quand même aller se laver manger
l'avait-on la main pour photos et cissé
porno c'est que med ce couple de
trentenaires n'oubliera jamais ce mois
de galère où ils n'avaient que leur
voiture pour survivre les nuits glacées
les morsures du gel une descente aux
enfers qui a laissé des traces
comprenez la couverture
malgré comme vous pouvez voir c'est
vraiment forfaits vont se chauffer je
m'étais le chauffage à fond
tac
je vais s'échauffer deux heures et quand
nous avons tellement fier parce qu'il
faut savoir que l'on économise autonome
et gasoil donc on est ma petite bonbonne
bleus
pour des couvertures ont été comme sur
la plupart du temps le bloquer on l'a
lui même
si c'est dangereux cessa jamais été
recommandée mais j'ai prochain c'est un
instinct de survie
si je fais pas ça joubert
ne dit pas vous réchauffer en ville dans
des centres commerciaux moi je veux
j'avais honte de m'afficher j'avais
honte honte de
dessus et revoir parce qu'on était ça on
était connue quoi on voulait pas qu'ils
disent va regarder où ils sont restés
joue on a caché tout moi je me rappelle
à une personne qui était venu nous vers
discuter avec nous lors d'un décès
monsieur magic mais avait l'odeur sur
vous je me suis trouvé gêné quand tu me
dis donc j'ai dit monsieur oui je sens
je ne suis pas laver ça fait cinq jours
je dis j'y peux rien chef
et s'auto femafoot a même pleuré
cette ville où il ne voulait pas se
montrer nicolas et catillon pourtant
trouvé depuis des soutiens
les associations caritatives mais aussi
les commerçants du coin désormais ils
ont par exemple droit gratuitement
à leur pain quotidien
[Musique]
le statut d'auto entrepreneur de nicolas
les petits commerçants s'ils
reconnaissent tous
ses coups francs sont excellentes
monsieur rosich comme d'aucuns lui aussi
ça peut nous arriver en entreprise
individuelle dont 30 retrait individuel
individuel du bape à deux pas de fiche
de paye donc pas de fiche de paye pas de
chômage
après si nous on n'a plus rien même pas
et la maison on est en location on peut
pas payer le loyer donc automatiquement
on se retrouve comme dessus rose on n'a
plus rien c'est dommage qu'on l'ait pas
protégés par une autre quand même con à
dire que l'on puisse toucher quelque
chose tu toucheras construction mais non
il n'y a rien alors qu'une urne au
ballon de l'urss en profitent bien court
l'histoire de ce couple sans abri toute
la région la connaît grâce aux réseaux
sociaux
il y à un mois nicolas et cathy se sont
résolus à poster un appel à l'aide sur
facebook un appel entendu au delà de
leurs espérances
cette caravane c'est un internaute qui
leur prête gratuitement après avoir lu
leur message
bonsoir tout cela fait un mois que je
suis sdf avec ma femme et mon chien nous
vivons dans notre voiture nous n'avons
aucun revenu comme rsa assedic je vais
au restaurant du coeur je vais chez des
amis pour me wade lorsqu'il vous pris
des mois merci à tous ceux qui nous
aideront ça a été un élan de générosité
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin il ya 3 heures
du matin le téléphone n'a pas arrêté de
sonner le lendemain le lendemain
jusqu'aujourd'hui
de l'argent pour acheter un portable
beaucoup de nourriture et surtout de
quoi affronter le froid or tous nous
sommes au niveau des dons une solidarité
2.0 qui a sorti le couple de la rue des
retraités qui ont acheté un bon manteau
je le mets quand il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui émet vite à manger et
surtout partout donc en prendre
pour lui des couvertures comme ça c'est
pêche
parce que je n'avais pu eux des
pantalons
que ton rester un ou deux cours et une
veste qui tient chaud qu est en sueur
j'ai un peu à peu
pourriez
vous aviez quoi avant avant j'avais rien
sur moi
même si la situation s'est un peu
améliorée le quotidien reste précaire à
ne pouvoir compter que sur la solidarité
ce soir c'est un restaurateur du
quartier qui vient les soutenir
tout chaud
tout ce que j'ai deux pizzas offertes un
dîner de roi pour nicolas et cathy
bon appétit des sdf ce petit patron
n'imaginait pas en rencontrer à deux pas
de son commerce vous les voyez à la télé
ou réagissez pas pareil quand vous les
voyez en face quand vous voyez vraiment
la misère qui est en face de vous on
peut pas être insensible à ce genre de
choses
nous sommes tous pour nous ces meurtres
ça faisait longtemps que je ne pouvais
faire mieux a tout perdu je retrouvé
goût d'une pitié c'est bien si ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas mangé vous merci
du fond du coeur bonne soirée
[Musique]
derrière la détresse de nicolas la
nostalgie de la vie d'avant
et un peu d'amertume à l'égard des
politiques qui ne trouvent pas de
solution pour ceux qui comme lui ont
perdu pied nous te fier un
homme depuis que j'ai 18 ans j'ai jamais
voté de ma vie monsieur le président les
élus les ministres le tralala ils
devraient se dire ben oui c'est vrai il
ya des français dehors on a des
logements il ya combien de logements en
france qui sont vides combien une énorme
quand il y aura une loi pour les sdf tu
es dehors la commune une semaine sa
maison l'algérie voter mais pour
ne plus compter sur l'état mais plutôt
sur les autres pour aider à supporter
cette misère les français se montre
d'une solidarité parfois étonnantes
[Musique]
pour en prendre la mesure nous sommes
repartis sur les routes fait froid par
tout en auvergne les chaudières qui
tourne à plein régime aujourd'hui encore
dans la région - fax degrés ce matin
à montluçon
quelques bénévoles ont décidé d'apporter
un peu de chaleur à ceux qui n'ont plus
grâce au bois offert par la municipalité
met du pain venir
michel garnier le responsable des
jardins du coeur une émanation des
restos du même nom
sur le moment quand on a eu l'idée on se
disait mais peut-être converse il n'y a
peut-être pas besoin est très rapidement
les attentes sociales nous ont dit ben
on est là à vue de nez on a 80 familles
qui auraient besoin
dans cette camionnette
bonjour manu un retraité qui a fait 70
km pour récupérer son bois
non ça va vous ai trouvé un beau camion
la bassée c'est une loi d'un pouvoir
charger
au départ je me sentais mal à l'aise d'y
aller
mais bon encore heureux que j'arrive à
me trouver du doigt abane bien dépanner
quand même temps ça va me permettre de
pouvoir finir au moins libère
dans l'allier 15% de la population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté 2 points de
plus que le reste de la france
alors en ce moment michel et son équipe
livre du bois plusieurs fois par jour
salut à toi
rené à 64 ans elle vit avec son fils
steven dans ce petit pavillon situé à
une dizaine de kilomètres de montluçon
depuis deux ans cette ancienne ouvrière
ne se chauffent plus qu'au bois elle
attendait avec impatience sac yves
raison lâche unissait les derniers
morceaux n'a pas d'autre chauffage que
le bois et ce même si j'écris c'est une
femme âgée j'appelle mes nouveaux seuils
des radiateurs pc des grille-pain
donc c'est pour ça vous êtes au bois
est-ce que c'est mon budget parce que
nous mais avec ma petite retraite
auparavant rené n'utiliser que ces
grippes un
résultat une maison froide et un compte
en banque en surchauffe
ah oui ça c'est quand je me 4 avec la
facture de 1300 euros payés gc a fléchi
c'est pas possible je peux enfin vous
payé
1300 euros directement où ils font taire
des échéances parce que j'y arriverai
jamais appelé tout
chà 900 euros
quand j'ai fait le calcul j'ai regardé
jiwa pas vraiment c
j'ai commencé à travailler à l'âge de 14
ans et pour en arriver à gagner vraiment
une misère ces misères et après quand
j'ai réussi à voir du voile les factures
ou quand même
hormis angers si je suis passé à à 64
euros comme tous les mois s'il n'y avait
pas ce type d'initiative vous pensez que
vous arriveriez vous payez le bois non
pas du tout non
une situation tellement ordinaire
qu'elle devient difficile à supporter
pour les bénévoles comme mimi de plus en
plus une précarité chez presque tout le
monde ah oui ce sont
les arrivées à supporter savoir
ce que je supporte plus ce
qui est des gens peuvent payer
est-ce que je peux ferrand à part faire
du bénévolat c'est tout ce que je peux
faire je peux rien faire d'autre sport -
ouais à les revoir
[Musique]
la tournée continue ce jour là il reste
encore une dernière famille a livré une
maman seule
avec ses trois enfants dans une maison
mal isolée
vous n'êtes pas trop attendu non comme
sa bande et donc comme ça on est
toujours
colossal ah oui ah oui
c'est un très gros budget de chauffage
et ça mais là vers 3500 euros par an par
an
effectivement c'est un budget it c'est
le plus gros budget du foyer en fait
une fortune pour alexandra qui gagnent à
peine 1000 euros entre les allocations
et son salaire d'accompagnatrice de bus
scolaire
alors pour offrir de la chaleur toute
l'année à ses enfants alexandra doit
tirer un trait sur tout le reste
ils profitaient pas comme vous voulez ah
non non non ça fait 20 ans qui a 4 ans
et l'a jamais vu la mer des choses comme
ça c'est triste
[Musique]
voilà c'est un fort pour murray
on aimerait leur offrir la lune si
c'était possible les enfants
un jour
la précarité énergétique est une
précarité qui ne se voit pas une
souffrance que l'on garde pour soi
c'est compliqué d'en parler
mais c'est un sujet que vous n'avez pas
du tout
pourquoi
je sais pas l'on dit que les gens le
sachent
pas seulement un peu triste parce que
avant ça nous faisait pas pareil on
pouvait un peu plus se chauffer et par
rapport à maintenant barre ça coûte plus
cher et du coup bah c'est pas pareil
le jan nombreuses années en parler de la
précarité alimentaire avec le l'action
des restos du coeur mais la précarité
énergétique elle est bien présente
maintenant mais on entend moins parler
et pourtant elle est tout aussi
inconfortable quand vraiment on n'arrive
pas à chauffer son foyer en avait pas
livre à l'aise dedans j'ai l'impression
que c'est une sorte de nouvelle égalité
aujourd'hui pour faire quelques
économies
seule la cheminée chauffera la maison
cette nuit chez alexandra la température
descendra à 12 degrés
[Musique]
comment en est on arrivé à de telles
factures de chauffage
l'ufc que choisir étudie l'augmentation
du coût de l'énergie et au fil des ans
elle est devenue considérable
on constate sur l'électricité et sur le
gaz qui a effectivement une augmentation
depuis 2008 d'environ 20% sur le gaz est
de 35% sur l'électricité sur la facture
des ménages est essentiellement sur la
facture des ménages qui se chauffent
soit l'électricité soit au gaz c'est
beaucoup c'est énorme il faut savoir que
sur cette période là l'inflation est de
l'ordre de 8 à 10% donc on a bien au
delà de l'inflation ça représente 300
euros d'augmentation environ sur elvis
chauffent au gaz ça fait entre 180 et
200 euros de plus sur la période en
cause la hausse des cours mondiaux du
gaz et du fuel importé par la france et
les investissements que nécessite la
production d'électricité l'entretien des
centrales notamment nucléaires et des
réseaux d'acheminement électrique
la difficulté qui va se poser dans les
années à venir c'est que cette évolution
de prix va petit à petit finalement
intégrer des ménages qui étaient en
capacité de payer leurs factures et ben
vont avoir de plus en plus de
difficultés d'où l'enjeu aujourd'hui de
traiter le mal à la racine c'est-à-dire
le bâti l'iso l'isolation du bâti mais
des fois ils n'ont pas la possibilité
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont en
location et que la difficulté
aujourd'hui qu'on a dans le bâti c'est
que le bailleur ne payant pas la facture
d'énergie n'est pas inciter à faire des
travaux de rénovation énergétique c'est
le locataire qui payent la facture et le
locataire n'a pas à faire les travaux de
rénovation énergétique puisqu'il ne sait
pas s'il va en bénéficier longtemps en
france deux tiers des habitations soit
20 millions de logements sont considérés
comme des passoires thermiques
nous partons pour l'est de la france
en alsace plus d'un foyer sur quatre est
touché par la précarité énergétique
le froid frappe en pleine ville et
parfois aux portes d'un immeuble tout
entier
schiltigheim dans la banlieue de
strasbourg
cette résidence date des années 80 une
construction moderne pourtant à tous les
étages et locataires se gèle la famille
d'inès habite au premier
donc ça c'est la pièce principale
donc le chauffage là il est donc serein
sur un thermostat normal donc qui
devrait chauffer les sur thermostat 3
donc ça devrait faire à peu près 18
degrés sur un thermostat 3
donc il est effectivement le voyais en
hiver donc il est censé être allumées
l'essentiel ce sont pourtant les froids
maintenant si je veux avoir de la
chaleur je suis obligé de le mettre sur
six ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
c'est sûr sûr sûr consommation
avec un radiateur capricieux et -9
degrés à l'extérieur ce jour là le froid
s'infiltre partout mais inès sait
comment dompter cet invité encombrants
donc là je ferme les volets pour garder
la chaleur puisque à partir de 16h30
le froid commence à rentrer ça permet de
garder la chaleur
donc je mets mon petit j'ai aussi pour
éviter d'être trop remonter le chauffage
inès vit avec deux de ses quatre enfants
elle a perdu son travail et son mari
enchaîne les missions d'intérim il
touche entre 900 et 1300 euros par mois
entre se chauffer et aller au
supermarché il a fallu choisir
gecko les restos du coeur pour faire des
courses donc ils vendent beaucoup de
concerts où ces pratiques pour le repas
il donne ça c'était gratuit par exemple
une confiture la revue aussi la lessive
et donc avec ça et effectivement on se
débrouille toi
jusqu'à présent hynes a toujours voulu
honorer ses factures d'électricité
mais les retards s'accumulent
nous avons donc un impayé à ce jour 2
485 euros mais en sachant que malgré cet
impayé il faut quand même payer tous les
mois 148 euros de
prélèvements en plus de certains pays
hynes a bien reçu un bon de chauffage de
120 euros de la part de la mairie mais
elle n'a droit à aucune autre aide
les revenus de la famille sont juste au
dessus des barèmes pour avoir droit aux
tarifs sociaux des fournisseurs
d'électricité ont fait partie des des
gens qui ont quand même à revenus
donc pour avoir la moindre elle il ya
deux mois d'attentes 2 à 3 mois
d'attentes pascal eydoux ses affaires il
ya des conditions d'attribution
il ya les ressources si vous dépassez
les 5 600 euros de revenus on ne pouvait
rien à voir on vous donne rien dans tout
l'immeuble l'histoire se répète des
familles en difficulté mais surtout
soumise au bon vouloir du bailleur
social
l'immeuble est un celle m non
conventionnés ni les loyers ni
l'entretien comme le chauffage ne sont
réglementés on a le même problème les
appartements c'est du chauffage
électrique c'est mal isolés et comme on
pouvait constater il ya beaucoup de
volets qui sont quand même fermé
on ferme pour éviter de faire entrer
froid au deuxième étage de cet immeuble
plein de courants d'air habite sa soeur
jeanine
elle aussi en a ras-le-bol voilà quatre
pages à remplir je crois que je vais
m'éclater c'est comme si quelqu'un qui
aime s'éclater en 20 sec
elle compte bien le faire savoir dans l'
enquête de satisfaction que le bailleur
vient tout juste de lui envoyer
concernant ce fonctionnement est l'état
des équipements de votre logement alors
du chauffage a
bâti son bailleur refuse de remplacer
ces radiateurs et donc un liquide dedans
est là actuellement j'ai un petit bol en
dessous parce que j'ai le mythique col
du radiateur et c'est hyper dangereux
c'est comme si on mettait de l'antigel
c'est exactement pareil et donc si on en
est entre les mains ou si les animaux
moi j'ai dit j'ai un chat il le bois
vingt cinq ans mais on ne nous change
pas il ça fait deux ans que le bas et on
parle pas des fenêtres quand vous pouvez
voir angers une fission et toutes ces
fenêtres lacets rouges et ici j'ai le
froid qui passe et quand on vous même
quand c'est fermé manger le passage
d'air et nous les change pas au rez de
chaussée c'est encore pire
jeanine nous emmène voir sa voisine de
80 ans pour ça
commence à voir en ce moment avec le
chauffage s'économise comme je peux
l'appartement de colette est un vrai
frigo
voyez ces dalles normalement fin chant
échec un petit raté mais
c'est 1000 euros de retraite ne lui
permettent pas de chauffer toutes les
pièces
elle a donc migré au salon
j'adore mais ici aussi le froid
s'infiltre partout
ça va il allait rentrer
des deux côtés
déjà les loyers sont exorbitants tous
que c'est alors d'aider des gens comme
ça mais moi je trouve pas ça humain
c'est inhumain au bout d'un moment 21e
siècle font réagir nous avons contacté
le bailleur de l'immeuble il se dit
conscient des problèmes et promet de
tenir compte des plaintes des locataires
heureusement en plein coeur de l'hiver
l'horizon s'éclaircit parfois
ans
[Musique]
le petit village de la broque est situé
au pied des vosges
les maisons sont anciennes certaines
encaissé le vent glacial s'y engouffre
le soleil lui ni vient jamais
schéma dit il fait à peine 10 degrés
mais voilà
en face à des foules autrefois il
faisait tellement froid ici que en plus
si c'était bien il est un ami je les
prie et mon café avec ça sur la tête
faut le faire quand même
on n'est pas chez les ch et les rues
saint dans la toundra
cette retraitée de 70 ans a acheté cette
maison il y a deux ans
j'avais fini
mais elle n'a pas réalisé qu'elle était
en si mauvais état les murs transpire de
froid s'effrite rien ne tient à crochets
et m'a dit grelotte ça fait pas relâche
nos fins au pasqua
m'a dît se chauffe au pétrole
et au bois quand il reste un peu
d'argent à la fin du mois sur ses 1100
euros de retraite
rien n'y fait l'odeur du pétrole et de
l'humidité et entêtante la chaleur
inexistante
qu
un autre pub
ça un t-shirt à lachenaie ce jeu vous
avez vidé bizarre voilà ça fait betts a
fait ça fait grossir mais à mon âge de
toute façon je ne tiens pas à plaire à
quelqu'un je tiens à avoir chaud
la vie de maddie fait de sacrifices
devrait bientôt changer
[Musique]
l'association se lia solidarité pour
l'habitat va l'aider à rénover sa maison
cinquante six mille euros de travaux
pour isoler les fenêtres les portes
refaire le toit
[Musique]
voilà on revient pour faire un peu le
point avec monsieur simona de façon à
vraiment prioriser les travaux liés à
l'énergie mais façon pas puissent faire
le projet global a compris les problèmes
liés à la sécurité
l'électricité etc et puis bien sûr
régler votre problème de mobilité voilà
mady a des problèmes pour marcher le
froid et l'humidité la fragilise un peu
plus
l'association va trouver les entreprises
de rénovation et les fonds pour financer
les travaux regardez les gouttes
d'aulaqi qui perd là haut ça s'entraîne
on va dire du problème a pris position
des champignons qui sont pour la santé
pour la santé pour le système
respiratoire
les moisissures colonise toute la pièce
mais si tout va bien
grâce aux subventions mahdi n'aura rien
à payer
qu'on va essayer de faire au mieux voilà
pour que madame dubois pages encore de
belles années la voilà dans un logement
quand même qu'on les envoie la
d102 confortable
schéma dit les travaux devraient
démarrer dans les prochaines semaines
dans un nom elle passera enfin l'hiver
au chaud
[Musique]